the people i see
as representative of high quality
left thinking are typically categorized
as on the right
in order to dismiss them which leaves
the left
nominally under the control of people
advocating things that
very frequently when i hear these
formulations
i feel like it would take adults
10 minutes of discussion to figure out
why these things
don't work can't be tried and
to just put the ideas to bed but instead
we're going to take apart civilization
in order to run an experiment the
outcome of which is
absolutely certain so
something about the veto power which is
obviously in part the result of
an empowerment that comes from social
media um
i i have mentioned to others that i
think
we are suffering the consequences of
um the loss of the role of leadership
that leadership
has been demoted to the status of
influencer and that the problem is
influencer
is a producer consumer
modality and the consumer is at the
point that a leader
might tell you something that you don't
want to hear but you need to know
a uh an influencer may say it and people
will switch to some influencer that's
less likely to cause them angst
and that that that loss of leaders is
resulting
in you know just the most
foolish beliefs rising as if
they are new as if they have
meaningful content as if they can even
be spelled out
in some sort of consistent form that
would allow you to evaluate them when
really
in each case they run through your
fingers like water
i i think the the crisis of leadership
is actually key to a lot of this because
the thing that is is very striking
is um you know a lot of the kind of the
woke mob
or all these these gangs of social media
vigilantes who go after anyone who says
something disagreeable
you know they are quite scary in the
sense that they are obviously unhinged i
mean there's a real
problem here i mean they're often quite
hateful individuals
i get the most obscene emails from
people like this
threatening things and saying things
which
are really objectionable and they behave
in a very very bad way if you look at
jk rowling for example who's getting a
lot of abuse at the moment because she
believes in biological sex which is
blasphemy in in the woke era
you know they do things they send her
pornographic pictures
or if she posts a tweet about a
children's
book and lots of children respond to her
these people will post pornographic
pictures in those discussion threads
this is not normal behavior this is
unhinged
regressive incredibly anti-human
anti-social behavior so they are
sometimes quite scary but but the other
striking thing about them is that they
they're often very small in number so
when i've encountered controversies on
at british universities where there have
been groups of people
protesting against a visit of mine for
example
you know it's they're always fairly
small in number
they're always quite socially awkward
strange
young people uh you know we're not
talking about
vast numbers of well-adjusted
human beings so the question i always
ask myself is how is it possible
that these mobs of strange people have
such a big influence and i think
you've actually nailed it it's it's the
interplay between
the um the vociferous nature of these
people and their censorious desires it's
the interplay of that
with the crisis of leadership and with
the crisis of institutions
and i think one of the main players in
the current climate is
institutional cowardice the way in which
institutions just
roll over as soon as seven people
write them an email saying you know take
down this
monument or rename your um halls of
residence
or take down that bust of someone who
died
200 years ago there are so many
institutions who just nod along
and do as they are told or big companies
you know big companies
all it takes is for a handful of people
on twitter
to tell netflix or some other big
company that they are advertising on a
controversial website or they're
advertising on a right-wing magazine
for those in those corporations to
withdraw their adverts
there's so little backbone that you know
no one's willing to stand up and of
course
all of this is just gives a green light
to the mob it feeds
their desires it feeds their sense of
power and so i think there's a really
close
um connection between those two things
and i think the the failure of
politicians
to take a stand against this stuff is
also very striking
you know when trump gave his mount
rushmore speech
recently um on the fourth of july
and he talked about cancel culture it
was actually a really good speech
i have no idea who wrote it i'm pretty
sure trump didn't write it but it was a
really good speech
not very well delivered um but it was a
really good speech and it was so
striking that he
this was the first time a major
politician had said things like this
where he said they want to cancel the
american revolution they want to cancel
the ideas of western civilization and
that's absolutely correct
and so um if more people did what trump
did at mount rushmore
i think we'd probably be in a better
position so
that's a really key point and i think um
what's becoming more and more clear over
time
is that this is an assault on western
civilization
and if you look at the mania of the past
few
weeks in relation to black lives matter
and tearing down statues and everything
else
you know on the surface it looks like an
attack on confederate statues or statues
of slave owners and
you know not many people are going to
lose sleep over a statue of a slave
owner being torn down in bristol in
england
fine who cares but it's not just about
that
this is part of a broader campaign which
depicts
modern western history as one crime
after another
the way in which america is currently
talked about as this
disgusting sinful racist country you
know racism is the original sin of the
american republic which it will never
wash clean and
you know and this conscious effort on
the part of new york times
type people to to change the founding
date of america from 1772
to 16 19 is so interesting
because that's really an effort by
sections of the liberal elite
or the the illiberal elite to
rewrite history itself to to re-fashion
america as a country that was founded in
sin
founded in crime rather than one that
was founded in revolution and the search
for freedom and the first amendment and
all those other wonderful things
the same thing is happening in the uk
the way that left-wing activists and
often school teachers and university
educators the way they talk about
britain
you'd think it was the most evil country
that ever existed
all we hear about is the slave trade and
empire and colonialism and all these
things
which had many many many terrible
consequences around the world no one's
doubting that
we don't hear about the english
revolution we don't hear about the
chartist movement for democracy we don't
hear about the
struggle in the 1600s for press freedom
which
influenced the founding of america to a
large degree we don't hear about the
magna carta we don't hear about
england as the birthplace of liberty in
many ways
so there's a conscious effort on the
part of this emerging elite
to um to reimagine western history as
just a litany
of crimes and i think that's something
that is absolutely essential to stand up
to yeah i
resonate with all of this the cowardice
is
breathtaking and you know it's rooted in
a very simple
game theoretic comparison between
my ability to get through today in the
face of a mob that's threatening me
and our ability to get through next week
and so what's happening is that
corporations individuals colleges are
all making the same calculation which is
they're solving their today problem
at the expense of a much larger tomorrow
problem
and it is um you're
a hundred percent right about the attack
on western civilization and the funny
thing is
i remember the moment at which i became
aware of this
during the evergreen meltdown i
detected that this was what was going on
and i
said out loud i believe it was in a
faculty meeting
that not only was this
an attack on the institution but this
this was really an attack
on not only the enlightenment but the
concept of enlightenment
and what came back was not
the um denial that i expected it was an
embrace of what i had just said and the
idea was
right enlightenment is a white people
thing
it's bad it is you know the root of
slavery and all other you know uh sins
and therefore we are right to tear it
down and i just thought my god
what are what are we playing with here
you know we're really at root dealing
with
whether we will have any agreement that
would allow us to establish
even a single claim on some basis other
than
power right you know we saw on
twitter very recently a battle over
whether
two plus two actually equals four and of
course
that has a history in literature but the
fact that people were actually earnestly
arguing this tells us where we are
and it has caused me to think the
following
thought i don't think almost anybody is
this dumb
right i don't think as you point out
these are tiny
movements but they're not even it's not
even this tiny number of people who
believes these things i think
almost nobody believes these things and
that in effect they are like
a uniform and they are simply declaring
i am with those people
and the fact is what's frightening is i
am with those people those people may
well have the power to uninvent
the west and if they do
we will be left with tyranny
and then maybe we will reinvent the west
later
if we survive to do it but
the question is really one of net effect
there are obviously major structural
problems
in the west there is a problem with
inequity if we
use the standard definition of that term
rather than
the modern fashion but did the west
accomplish
vastly more than it has failed to
accomplish
it did and so uninventing it over that
which it has not
attained is lunacy
and yet uh somehow
i have to tell you all the people with
enough wealth to pick up and move
seem to be fleeing cities because
somehow
even though there is no evidence
whatsoever that the populace wants the
police defunded
we are now watching the defunding of
police because
we think some mob is demanding it when
in fact
we don't even know you know the mob
because it doesn't have leaders
we can't say what fraction of the people
who are attacking federal buildings
uh actually advocate the abolition of
the police what fraction of them want
police budgets reduced what fraction of
them uh
is simply out to make mayhem but in any
case it isn't civilization demanding
this
it is the tiniest fraction that is now
apparently in a position to dictate
terms to the rest of us
yeah i think um
we are living through a bourgeois
reaction against
the enlightenment and it's terrifying
actually
and um you see it all the time now you
know
the very idea of reason is called into
questions so often these days the
existence of free will the desirability
of freedom of speech
a belief in in the autonomy of human
beings or the potential autonomy of
human beings all these ideas that drove
well first the renaissance and then the
enlightenment are explicitly called into
question now particularly on campuses
but in the political sphere
more broadly and um
and and what we're living through is a
reaction against the enlightenment it's
a counter enlightenment movement
made up of various different groups of
people there's the noisy brigade
the kind of woke mob who are the most
explicit in their regressive
backward views there are the
institutions which are increasingly
incapable of
standing up for the values that they
were founded to stand up for
so you have museums in the uk for
example and museums around the west in
fact
which are now beating themselves up
constantly about what they can put on
display
whether they should send certain
artifacts back to africa or
or back to greece or back to wherever
they might have come from
um no sense that they might have a
you know an intellectual responsibility
to uphold the value of the enlightenment
the idea that you could study things
that you could collect things that you
could improve man's understanding of
himself through
founding these kinds of institutions for
the public good
even at that level the values of the
enlightenment
moment are just being trashed all the
time often by the people who are
supposed to be upholding them
one of the things i find most grotesque
in all of this
is something you've mentioned there
about
the way in which the enlightenment is
seen as a white people thing
um you know that's that's for white
people less for europeans
you know let's talk about what what
black people need or what minority
groups need and
you know apparently they need a form of
politics that is
less based in reason less based in
science i mean we've seen some stuff
over the past few days and weeks
in which ideas like time keeping are
described as a white
trait or a belief in the exercise of
reason
over passion is seen as a white trait
this is explicitly
racist i mean i i always was concerned
that woke politics
would rehabilitate racial thinking
through through the identitarian
ideology
but it's actually just rehabilitating
racism because if you think
white people are good at keeping to time
and understanding the world in a
scientific reasoned way
but black people are not you are a
racist i have news for you you're a
racist person
[Music]